good evening members and officers of the
council and members of the public
welcome to this meeting of the
governance and audit committee firstly
i'll just go through the fire evacuation
procedure um if the fire alarm is
activated please vacate the offices by
the stairs either through the security
door behind me or opposite the lifts in
the foyer please do not use the lifts
please assemble in halle square on the
green officers will assist you and
advise when it is deemed safe to return
to the chamber
filming does anyone intend to film the
meeting
great
any member of the public who objects to
the possibility of being filmed maybe
she said it's opportunity to leave the
meeting but i don't think anyone's
filming so that's great
restriction on use for mobile phones
would everyone present please ensure
their mobile phones are turned silent
and that they are not used to make or
receive phone calls in the chamber while
the meeting is in progress
please note this meeting is being live
streamed
we think
and for members of the public the
meeting will also be recorded and will
subsequently broadcast on the council's
youtube channel
under rule 20.1 would any member and
member who wishes to speak under council
procedure rule 22.1 please announce it
now
great um agenda item one the produce for
absence apologies has been received from
councillor duckworth are there any other
apologies for absence
gender item two declarations of interest
are there any declarations of interest
gender item 3 minutes of the meeting
held on 20th july 2021 to approve the
minutes of the meeting held on 20th july
21 copy attached to the agenda pack
please gonna have a proposer and a
seconder
councillor pugh
and councillor town in second
thank you
unless i hear any objection i will take
these as approved
thank you um gender item 4 quarterly
internal updates report um i mainly
introduce simon webb from east kent
audit partnership who will reintroduce
the report
thank you chair good evening members
this is our regular quarterly internal
audit update report summarizing the work
of the internal audit partnership on
your behalf in the last quarter together
with details of our performance to the
30th of september
if i could draw your attention to the
table on page 15 that summarizes the six
new pieces of work undertaken during the
quarter
we were pleased to report substantial
assurance in the areas of procurement
and also payroll which is undertaken on
your behalf by escaping hr
um
tenant health and safety we were
particularly pleased to report
reasonable assurance overall in this
area if you could draw your attention to
the table on page 19
that summarizes a breakdown of the
assurance levels between the various
areas of tenant health and safety
very pleasing to see substantial and
reasonable assurance
in areas such as fire safety gas safety
uh legionella
particularly considering the uh state
that you inherited this from uh from
east kent housing and the very very low
levels of insurance we had at that time
it is a very substantial
increase in assurance level and that
really is a tribute to bob porter and
his team in the housing section
um there's one area um fairly minor
where we're currently reporting limited
assurance and that's general needs
housekeeping within communal blocks um
that should be fairly easy to fix and we
would hope to report at least reasonable
assurance in that area when we come back
with a follow-up
going back to page 15
um
ict software licensing we've reported
largely reasonable but partially limited
assurance in that area and the reasons
for that are detailed in the bullet
points on page 20 and 21.
commercial-led properties and
concessions
unfortunately we concluded limited
assurance in that area and again the
reasons for that opinion are detailed in
on pages 21 and 22
particularly surrounding
not having up-to-date rent reviews
we would hope to see
an increase in assurance in that area by
the time we come to undertake the
follow-up and that will of course be
reported to a future meeting of this
committee
follow-up is of course a very important
part of the internal audit work
approximately three to six months after
every internal audit we go back
to see if the recommendations contained
in the agreed action plan have been
implemented
and also to revise the assurance level
if that is deemed appropriate
during the period under review we
undertook one um follow-up which was of
cemeteries and crematoria and the
assurance level there has raised
from reasonable to substantial that is
detailed on page 24 of the agenda pack
page 26 of the agenda pack um annex one
shows progress to date against um
the family history council 2122 agreed
internal audit plan
um
as at the 30th of september
we had completed 43.7
of the
council's agreed plan
fractionally behind the 50 target at the
six-month state each however i can
update you to the 30th of november
yesterday
we were up to 63 percent um against the
eight-month target of 66
so very much on target to complete uh
substantially uh the council's plan by
the 31st of march
that and the other kpis relating to the
east kent audit partnership are detailed
within the balanced scorecard
and that is on page 32 and 33
of the agenda pack that concludes my
presentation chair obviously happy to
take any questions that members may have
thank you
thank you
members do you have any questions or
comments you'd like to make
councillor whitehead
thank you very much no questions thank
you very much for the update
um
just to echo what you said in relation
to housing really
they've had
an extraordinarily difficult job
and they've dealt exceptionally well
with it even in pandemic circumstances
so i think it's very pleasing to see
this and they deserve a lot of praise
for that
thank you
any other questions or comments
okay brilliant um mr webb um just one
comment sorry there we go um based on
the ict licensing i know obviously it
says that it's uh previous audit reviews
have highlighted this requirement uh as
um
as hard as well and different solutions
from bespoke software to simple
spreadsheets have been agreed
applications have not not been
implemented is there any reason why
this is this problem is still there from
the previous
audio because i think i remember seeing
this couple of years ago as well so is
there any reason that they've given us
to why the licensings haven't been
updated
thank you chair um yes it has been an
issue for a while i didn't know chris if
you wanted to come in on this item
thank you simon yes um i
am
the
interim head of shared services at the
moment which means i have responsibility
for ict under the er east shared service
partnership i'm afraid i can't actually
give a a full uh answer to the moment
chair but i have um literally just sent
that across to
dan evans the head of ict
this evening just as simon was giving
his presentation for an update on who is
leading on that in the moment and be
able to give you a response in writing
after the meeting
bring it thank you chris
so the recommendation is that the report
be received by numbers
and any changes to the agree 2021-22
internal audit plan resulting from
changes in perceived risk detailed at
point 5.0 of annex one of the attached
report be approved please can have a
proposer and a seconder
proposed by councillor cup and seconded
by councillor pew
unless i hear any objection i will take
this as approved
thank you
moving on to agenda item 5
a mid-year review
2021-2022 treasury management annual
investment strategy with the director of
finance clis chris blundell please
introduce the report
thank you chair uh so this is the first
of two treasury management reports i've
got tonight's aren't you lucky um so
this first one is the mid-year reports
so it's it's looking at our position
where we are in the current financial
year for 21 22 at the half year 0.2
halfway through september this report's
already gone to cabinet it went to cabin
on the 16th of november and subject to
any comments or recommendations that the
committee would want to make it will now
go on to
the next full council meeting
so
just as a bit of a reminder treasury
management is all about how we manage
our cash flows our borrowing and our
investment
a large part of it is about how we
manage our capital expenditure in terms
of the capital program and putting them
borrowing in place to finance those
capital plans um in other words it's
making sure we've got enough cash in
place to pay the bills when they become
due
i'm pleased to report that there's uh i
don't envisage with us meeting
any problems meeting
the targets that have been sat on the
limits that were sat in the strategy
that was approved back in february
so just to give you an overview of some
of the headlines in the report in terms
of capital spending that's set out in
section four
of the report um and at section 4.2
you'll see that at the mid year point
we'd spent 5 million pounds of our
revised three 31 million pound
uh
capital budget for 21.22 so that
obviously is below where we'd want to be
at this point of the year there was much
more detail provided for the reasons of
that in the mid year monitoring report
that also went to the same cabinet
meeting
just below that it does give you an
overview of some of the the schemes or
that have
not had any spend against them those
schemes that have got budgets in excess
of half a million pound in the general
fund
and also there's some schemes that are
lagging behind on the hra as well so
it's expected that those schemes will
catch up towards the end of the year but
i think it's unlikely that we will spend
the full revised budget
the same section so if you move across
to 4.3
that shows how our revised capital
budgets will be financed so um at the
start of the year we were expecting
that um
our budget would be 20 just shy of 22
million pound for the capital program
but our revised budget is now 31 million
pound um so it's quite a sizeable jump
but i'm pleased to say the majority of
that is just from
um grants and there's only going to be a
modest increase in borrowing
so that's a sort of overview where we
are for borrowing for the year
looking in terms of our investment
that's covered off in section five
section five shows that we have about 54
million pounds worth of investments at
the midpoint a year that's pretty much
all in
very low risk money market funds um the
average return that we're getting on
those funds is 0.007
so it's a very very low rate of interest
it's next to nothing um interestingly
the benchmark that's provided is that we
get a negative return so we're beating
the benchmark in the fact that we're not
paying our banks to give them our money
so that's that's
that's a minor win
um
in terms of um
uh borrowing uh small detail on that our
borrowing position in section six
shows that we had approximately 20
million pounds of external borrowing at
the mid-year point there's no new
borrowing undertaken during the first
half the year
but we have repaid about four million
pounds during the year so far so opening
balance on our debt was about 24 it's
now down to
20.
we are going to look very carefully at
our borrowing position in the second
half of the year interest rates are low
at the moment and forecast to increase
um particularly uh even this month
there's some speculation that the bank
of income may increase rates slightly so
we are monitoring that position and we
will consider whether we need to take
some more debt
on board earlier than we initially
planned
um so just to wrap this report up
members are asked to make any comments
before it goes forward to council for
approval
happy to take any questions share
thank you chris any questions or
comments from members
counselor pete
thank you chair and uh thank you chris
for your report i have a few a couple of
questions and i'm going to start the one
at the end because it's the one that i'm
on the page of it so it's page 58 i
believe it's annex 1.3 is debt maturity
um and i just wondered if you could just
speak in a bit more detail particularly
about the graph
because i think i mentioned this at our
last meeting actually um about when our
debt will mature and particularly the
ones that are 10 to 20 years and what
the risk would be to us as a council but
um i was wondering if you could just
provide a bit more detail in
particularly in the
debt that's set to mature in under a
year
and how much that may be a risk to us or
if that impacts on our investment um and
then yeah i'll come back so i've got
another question about something yeah if
that's okay yeah because i've got to
flip back you see chris because thank
you uh yes if you look at the that that
chart that uh
has been identified in page 58 this
shows the debt maturity at 31st
september as i've already mentioned
earlier we'd already paid off four
million during the year so that's not
included in that so there's a further
four
and a bit million pound that we're
expecting to repay this year um it's
likely we refinance that debt and take
on additional borrowing at that time
uh you can see them beyond that
there's not a there's not a a great
amount or a large proportion of our debt
profile that's coming up for maturity
over the next five years then there's a
relatively large tranche of it that
falls between 10 to 20 years
in terms of our our risk of being able
to refinance it that doesn't have a huge
bearing on us because we are currently
under borrowed and what i mean by that
is
we have a borrowing need in terms of how
much we need to borrow to finance all of
our capital plans all all of the um
the schemes that we have in our capital
program they obviously have a borrowing
need
we there's two ways you can finance that
firstly you can go out to
[Music]
the markets and see if you can get
private investment secondly the route we
tend to
take is to use pwlb and those are the
two external routes you can get to
actually get debt on board with the
council
the alternative to actually getting debt
on board
is to use your own cash and we've said
we've got quite a lot of cash washing
around around 50 million pound so
instead of taking borrowing on we tend
to use our own cash balances to fund
those schemes
as i said we're looking at that strategy
at the moment whether we want to
actually lock some of that debt in
instead going forward and we probably
will refinance because the the risk of
interest rates going up there's not a
huge amount of debt that needs to be
refinanced over the longer term but
still like four million pound it
probably makes sense to refinance it
sooner rather than later rather than
effectively
using our cash balances now
and then having to take that debt on in
a few years time when we expect rates
will be a bit higher and the next report
i've got there's a forecast from our
consultants and they're expecting
interest rates to get up to about 1.25
percent
base rate with it by about um 2025.
so those are the risks that we're
concerning because when we expect
interest rates to go up we're more
likely to take borrowing on sooner
rather than later so in terms of that
profile that chunk that four million
pound is the amount that we're looking
to refinance and when it comes due for
repayment we were most likely to take
out a new loan rather than using our
cash balances if that makes
sense uh councillor pew
next question brilliant thank you very
much um that has certainly uh reassured
my fears um
next question is just on
in relation to page 36 of the report uh
as part of the bullet points it says as
the 30th of september 2021
council's investment balance was 54.2
million and then in brackets it says 30
of september 2021 uh 42.3 million i just
want to check i'm assuming that that's a
mistake and that it should say uh 30th
of september 2020
you're correct that is minister that's
right just want to check thank you chris
councillor towning
thank you thank you chris
i i want to go to 4.2
of your report
where you're talking about um capital
expenditure
and you've got a list of um six items
there
now the office refurbishment of three
million
um
has been sitting around in a number of
reports
and of course they you go through it and
you you has any of that money actually
been borrowed yet
uh and especially the refurbishment of
toilets which is .75 of a million um
could you tell us what has been boring
what hasn't been borrowed and where we
are with this all thank you
absolutely thank you thank you council
of towning in terms of those two schemes
in particular there's no borrowing in
the program set aside for them the the
plans for those two schemes in
particular have always been that they
would be financed through uh the
disposal of related assets
so
in terms of office accommodation
ultimately we would look at any sales
proceed that could be generated from
this site in particular and would
therefore then be utilized for
investment to the sum of around three
million pound
um for
any future office accommodation
requirements so until the
um
until the office accommodation plan and
the our asset management plan has sort
of progressed further and that's
something that is being considered
by our corporate management team
um that scheme effectively cannot there
cannot be expenditure against it until
um we've got a plan to sell it it may be
that expenditure starts beforehand and
there's some form of
bridging arrangement a bit like a
bridging loan but ultimately it will be
financed through the receipt of a cell
of this and or other related office
accommodation
similarly with the public toilet
expenditure that has been
put in the scheme
up to a value of three-quarters of a
million but all expenditure on on public
toilet refurbishment would be funded
through the disposal of existing public
toilets and again
there's not been
any
recent disposals to my knowledge and
that's why there's not been any
expenditure against those that scheme as
well
well we all know that the the toilet
situation in in thailand is rather acute
to say the least
uh and interest rates currently being
low and we've got a bit of money
sloshing around as you quite rightly
pointed out don't you think it'd be
prudish that we borrow that uh
three-quarters of a million and get
these stories sorted out
whilst the money is available at a lower
interest rate
um obviously the the the cost of
borrowing is very low in terms of the
interest rate that we can get it but if
we were to borrow that money we would
have to repay it and that should the
debt repayments would still be
significant so for example
um if i just finish this point
chair and then i'll let council a cup
come in if we were to
um
if we were to borrow
three quarters of a million pound we
could borrow that money relatively
cheaply and the interest payments
associated but it would be pretty modest
however we'd have to find
revenue
budgets or our reserves ultimately to
repay
that sum of three quarters of a million
a pound or alternatively what we're
saying
because we don't have that money
available to us we need the disposal
from sites that was
at least the initial plan when the
scheme was put together in order to fund
any um related
expenditure that would uh result in the
refurbishment of the public toilets
yep the fire chair if i can hand back
over to you now
i just come back
i mean the problem with disposal of the
toilets okay
because they're in such a terrible state
no one is prepared to take them on if we
refurbish them there's a greater
opportunity to actually dispose of them
and recoup
that money that we've actually borrowed
maybe that should be considered
[Music]
yeah of course i can um so
we are currently looking at a toilet
strategy um to see what we can do
regarding toilets
um it's a strategy that is looking at a
whole concept of ideas whether that is
engaging with the communities whether
it's engaging with parish councils
community interests companies
to see what investment or assets we can
either way to increase an income
so then we can
refurbish some of the toilets
or whether or not it's a case that we
can encourage the community to offer up
toilets and businesses but
the the draft of this strategy is
currently being discussed and once we've
finalized it of course then it will be
in a better situation where we can uh
look into it more
but what i will say is that we are
putting a plan together to ensure that
there is a
um
an update of our toilets and to make
sure that they are in a better state for
the whole of the district because
believe me
um
it's not something that i'm proud of the
state of our toilets and it's something
that needs to change and we are working
on it
thank you
thank you councillor cop um are there
any more questions for mr blondel uh
councillor garner
thank you yeah i've got a question from
the same list that councillor towning
was talking about but mine relates to
the parkway railway station
um allocation of two million pound which
i believe is
allocated from reserves
um i know there's
some conversations
um
quite recently
that that might be reduced because of um
funding from kcc i've been increased i
believe um we if we come to a resolution
of how much exactly we are gonna have to
pay towards the um parkway station
uh yes please
thank you for your question council
ghana um yes i mean there have been
discussions around ensuring that our
contribution to the parkway station is
proportionate to that of kcc's currently
our position is still that it's 2
million subject to the final
determination determination around the
cost of the project and kcc's actually
our actual allocation but that principle
is still in place it's just we're not in
a position yet to confirm exactly what
that proportion is
sorry can i just just a quick follow-up
do we know when we will
know what that will be
i suspect that will be probably nearer
towards the end of the delivery of the
project so probably i would say
we're probably waiting to about spring
next year before we really be in
a position to actually finalize that
decision okay
any further comments or questions
counselor tony
what
i haven't managed to find
is the actual um
uh how many hours of beach cleaning have
we costed in our budget for the coming
summer
uh
are there any figures any hours that you
could you know
advise us on chris
i'd like to but i don't think it's
really relevant to this report
in terms of this is a treasury
management report certainly something
that um i'm happy to to discuss with you
further counsellor
thank you um
if there's no further comments um i'd
like to move to the recommendation that
the governance and audit committee won
notes and makes comments on as
appropriate this report and annexes and
two recommends support and annexes
including the prudential and treasury
indicators that are shown and propose
changes to the 2021-22
treasury management strategy statement
to full council for approval please can
i get a proposal and a seconder
proposal councillor pew
and a secondary council accounting
unless i hear any objection i will take
this as approved
right it's approved uh moving on to
agenda item six um the treasury
management strategy statement minimum
revenue provision policy statement and
annual investment strategy for 20 22 23
may i reintroduce chris blundell
who will present the report
thank you chair
so this differs from the last one same
subject but different time periods and
now we're looking forward to what our
strategy will look like for the next
financial year
if i start us off
on page 66
this is looking at our capital
expenditure plans for the next three
years you'll see a table
on page 66
and
if you look the the last three columns
the bottom
row that gives the total expenditure of
39
4 14 and a half and almost 17 million
pounds so
spending around about 70 million pounds
on capital expenditure is forecast
over
our medium term
if you if we follow on to
the next page on page 67 that gives you
a breakdown of how that will be funded
the majority of it is
you can see it's actually coming from
grants on the third third
row down there particularly 16 million
pound coming in 22 23
and then there's also a
sizable chunk coming from hra reserves
that relates to a lot of the improvement
plans we're doing our tower blocks and
then the bottom
line in bold the net financing need
that's ultimately how much we need to
borrow to finance the rest of our
capital program so that totals around
about 11 million pound so that's
increase in our borrowing needs that
we've got over the medium term
moving forwards um in this section
there's a there's a requirement for
council to
reconfirm our minimum revenue provision
and that's effectively the policy that
we've got in place for the repayment of
debt please say there's no change
there's nothing to get overly excited
about here um
ultimately
any debts taken on before 2008 we can't
attribute to particular assets so we
just write that off over a 25-year
period beyond that
from 2008 we're able to link it to the
specific asset lice and that's how we
write that data debt off so it links to
the asset life which makes sense
section 3 on
again on page 69 this is looking at our
borrowing so
um
kind of the table
that we're looking at
just get to the right one my apologies
on uh page 70. it's given us some
information there on our gross debt
position there and you can see that
as we're kind of talking about earlier
the debt position is expected to
increase and that's in line with our
expectations it would be wise to take
debt on at this point in time so that's
in line with our strategy and our
thinking for the period on the top of
page 71 it gives you the profile
of
our
expected debts and the limits that we'll
have in place and these limits are
important because ultimately
if we go above those limits it would
take a or require full council
decision in order to reverse that
so the total debt or authorized limit
that we could have on our books without
a council decision is 126 million so
that's um quite an increase in where we
are at the moment but again just gives
you a flavor of controls we have in
place to require
member intervention if there was a need
to take on a large proportion of debt
uh looking through to uh
the skipping through the report there's
quite a lot of narrative there around
some of the risks
to interest rate forecast i mentioned
earlier it's on top of page 72 section
3.3
there's the forecast on the base rate so
at the moment our treasury advisors are
expecting that the mpc the monetary
policy committee will increase the
debate the bank rate that's the top line
on that
table to
0.25 percent and all the way up to 1.25
by march 25 so that's a steady increase
around about 0.25 percent
uh per year over that
time period
and then the following narrative sets
out some of the risks
around those projections as obviously
we're operating still in very uncertain
times
if we move forward to
section 3.4
there's our borrowing strategy again
just talking about the principles that
we've got in place that where we think
interest rates are likely to rise we're
more likely to take that on sooner
rather than later and that's that's the
situation we're really monitoring
closely at the moment moment
again now if we skip forward to 3.7
on page 79 this sets up the sources of
the sort of institutions that would look
at in terms of taking on debt um so
we've got uh primarily is the public
works loan board they're the the source
but then we could go out to market for
other areas uh local authorities uh it's
called the local local market but as we
say primarily shorter data maturity so
if you want to take some borrowing on
for less than a year local authority
markets is a reasonable avenue some
financial institutions but that's not
something we've looked at previously the
municipal bonds agency is a
collaboration of local authorities have
been looking to work together to try and
offer cheaper borrowing and then there's
some other government sources of funding
that can be
used as well
moving on to investment and our strategy
for investment
so that's kicks off in section four
again on page 79.
really the the key here is around
managing risk credit worthiness is our
key consideration in other words we
don't want to be lending money to
organizations institutions that we think
may go bust so that's our primary
concern because it's public money we
always want to make sure we can get it
back first and foremost
one other thing to note that's important
within this part of our treasury
strategy
is that most of our investments are
dated less than one year and we have a
limit that
investments of five million pounds in
total is the amount that we can place
for longer one year so it just again
gives you a flavor of some of the
controls we have in order to manage the
risk that we're facing
uh one other thing that's not really i
think um prominent enough in the report
my apologies for it and we'll make sure
it is in the council report it's
actually contained in annex five which
you can find on page 101 this is
relation to a consultation that's been
ongoing changes that government are
going to make to
the framework that we operate in
you can see under section 2 the main
change is that we're no longer going to
be allowed to make what are cons
considered or termed terminology is
non-treasury investments effectively
commercial investments local authorities
are no longer going to be able to make
that primarily for yield
we can make investments within the
district
but they would really need to have some
service objective linked to it primarily
regeneration is the usual
sort of avenue you can be looking at to
make that but there's been a lot of
concern of some local authorities we've
not been involved in it but there have
been some
local authorities including districts
taking on a large amount of borrowing in
order to invest in what's considered
risky commercial property such as
shopping centres
and places that are completely desperate
to the geography of the local authority
so that's something i want to make sure
that's more prominent than the
main report that will go to council but
that sums up our strategy in terms of
our treasury management activity for
next year happy to take any questions
chair
thank you chris um i'm just going to
read out the recommendations so that you
are aware prior to doing questions and
comments
um so the recommendations are the
governance and audit committee makes
comments on this report and answers as
appropriate recommends this report and
answers including each of the key
elements listed below to fork council
for approval
um the points below are as follows a the
capital plans prudential indicators and
limits for 2022 to 2023 to 2024 to 25
including the authorised limit
prudential indicator b the minimum
revenue provision mrp policy
see the treasury management strategy for
2022 to
and the treasury indicators the the
investment strategy for 2022-23 and
contained in the treasury management
strategy including the detailed criteria
e the capital strategy for 2022-23
and f the non-treasury investments
report for
2022-23 do members have any comments or
questions
okay and the only comment from me is on
item
it's obviously item six but page 65 uh
saying about previous training for
members was back in 2019. i think
there's only about five of us that were
on the committee at the time
and
so it was just a suggestion as to
whether we could have additional
training for governments and audit
committee members perhaps in the next
quarter
um just so that we've all got a good
refresh of what's going on if that's
possible
not a problem i'll speak to our advisors
and see when their availability is if
it's too far into the future we'll
arrange for members to provide something
instead i'm sorry officers to provide
something to members instead yeah you're
welcome to come and train some treasury
management you probably know about as
much as
perfect thank you chris um any other
comments
brilliant um so you've heard the
recommendation please can i have a
proposal and second for members to agree
the listed recommendations
proposed by councillor cup
seconded by councillor shrub unless i
hear any objection i will take this as
approved
that's approved moving on to agenda item
7 corporate risk management i will now
call upon mr blundell to introduce the
review of corporate risks
thank you chair you'll be pleased this
isn't a treasury management report
so this is our
our regular update for you
the standard format that you'll be
familiar with in terms of the
introduction so i'll go through some of
the changes to the
risk register compared to the last one
that's
presented to the committee in july
there's been increased risk for birth
four five so that's come back onto the
corporate risk register in terms of uh
high score and risk that have now been
presented to committee that's surrounded
to the
delays of the project and the need for
environmental impact assessment that
have obviously been
well reported
still forecast is important to note that
the project's still forecast to come in
on budget but obviously there is a risk
if there is any further delay that would
put that objective at risk
there's been no change to the score in
terms of cyber attack but i can report
that we are progressing with the
insurance quotation in fact we're
currently discussions with that with our
broker and experts we should know more
by christmas in terms of having that
coverage in place
there's been an increased risk off for
homelessness
we're seeing a surge in that era again
pressures both in terms of demand and
supply pressures so increase numbers of
people and also a reducing number of
properties that we can make available
for temporary accommodation so that's
manifesting itself in terms of about a
half a million pound overspend on the
budget this year
i'm sure this would be presented
differently uh now but at the time of
writing there there was a reduced risk
for covert 19 that's obviously before we
knew about um omicron
um and i'm sure if we were writing this
report now that that score would still
be at its highest uh
score available at the 16 unexpected we
reflect the next report as well
then a new risk that's entered is the
environment act that came into
legislation in november
we're uncertain exactly what that will
mean for us particularly in terms of any
funding that may become available
for the
requirements of the act
so we'll have to monitor that closely
and
see how that risk develops
in addition it was requested at the last
committee that there would be an annex
presented for the lower scoring risks so
you can see that follows on um on page
113 setting out three corporate risks
that are of a lower score but are still
being considered and monitored by
officers
happy to take any questions chair thank
you
are there any questions or comments
counselor pew
thank you chair and uh thank you chris
uh for that i only have uh one minor
question and it's about uh
it's all the way at the end on page 13
annex one which is um
the other minor i say minor risk but
medium risk that are included as per our
last committee meeting a few months ago
um it's just
one was to do with the burial space
and particularly
the idea not only of infill vacant spots
but
um
perhaps you could maybe provide a bit
more clarity in how the mitigating
actions have reduced it down by three
points um
when i mean i'm not of any knowledge of
how many
i you know i'm not particularly aware of
how many spaces we may be able to infill
ancient graves and stuff like that and
so maybe you'd be able to provide a bit
more clarity on that and also the third
one coastal safety information signage
is inadequate
i'm just keen to understand how
that has remained unchanged even though
a report has been done
um
but there are no funds available or
funds need to be found to influence the
signs surely that would mean that the
risk would increase
as even though a report has been
published we haven't been able to find
or looked into allocating the funds to
resolve that
thank you councillor
i don't have the detail to hand in terms
of the first
issue in burial space but something i
can take away unless
any other officers are able to find an
update that coastal safety i believe
the chief exec may correct me from wrong
here this is the scheme that we've been
looking at in terms of funding that's
become available through
conf and other sources so we are um we
are progressing with that and obviously
this report is written at a a particular
period in time um and that will be
reflected it's going forward anything
further you can add on that maddie
from
um yes in respect of the uh burial uh
spaces um i agree uh i'm not i'm not
sure why we've reduced that um i know
that actually is something that we're
considering uh alternatives around how
we deal with that issue but i think we
do need to come back to you formally on
on why that uh scoring has changed on
the um
it's just come to the top of my head as
well uh the minster parish council were
trying to negotiate with the landowner
for the new land at the top of tottenham
street
for a cemetery extension so maybe this
may be something that we as a council
could help with because
it was originally included within the
draft local plan and then it was removed
examination stage for the land that had
to be included as a cemetery extension
maybe it's something that we can help
them with because certainly if we were
able to extend the cemetery there in
minster that would probably help us and
alleviate this so sorry it just as you
were answering it came i suddenly
remembered
thank you and i'll i'll take that away
and we'll have a conversation about that
and come back on that because that's an
entirely valid point if we can mitigate
uh that lack of space elsewhere then we
need to be considering that as part of
our approach um the coastal safety
information signage is in relation to um
obviously ensuring there is no uh uh
we're we're mitigating any risk of harm
to the public and as a result of a
particular incident that occurred
during the late summer um i think um
chris if if the comp money can be used
to cover that then i think that's
entirely appropriate that we use it for
that but
i think you can be reassured that
actually this is important uh it's a
health and safety issue so we need to
find the funding for it so i'm fairly
confident we will uh obtain that whether
it's through conf money or alternative
sources
uh councillor ghana
thank you yeah i'd just like to ask
a question related to the
increased risk related to birth 45 i
mean i've seen the update for
the update for this report was
completed
a few weeks ago i believe so it's not
fully up to date
because since
since this report was done the marine
license application
was withdrawn
um so that's added some
further delays so that sort of i would
say that uh possibly increase the risk
um
associated with birth 45 but i don't
think
the risk can actually be increased from
what it is at the moment is it like a
number of the other
risks they're sort of at their
limit
which which sort of leads into another
quest
sort of question and comment really if
we've got a number of risks that are at
their limit
there isn't really anywhere for them
to go apart from
down so what actually is a process
i mean i could sort of link in with the
governance risk because obviously that's
been updated since the the update was
put on here that we've had the
extraordinary meeting we've agreed a
number of actions
and i guess
risk is at 4 4 we've got these actions
that have to be actioned
um
within a short period of time
how how do we actually monitor
or how do we reflect that some of these
actions might not be being progressed as
speedily as they should be but there's
nowhere for the risk to go you know
how
how does that work
you're correct accounts are gone they
are at their maximum so they can't be
increased any further in terms of the
way we assess the risk we look at um
it's a product of the
impact and the probability so the
likelihood of something happening and
the impact it would happen have if that
um and the scores effectively times
together so four
times four gives 16 as our top risk and
that's how the scoring has come together
for all
well for all the the schemes you've
mentioned and for all our high profile
schemes we will have action plans in
place where those and these actions
effectively are our mitigating actions
that will um help us to alleviate the
risks that are sort of inherent with
those uh particular uh uh items that
we're discussing
and they will be monitored throughout
the sort of the life cycle of that of
those risks
it's
with some of them it's it's difficult to
um with some there's more than that we
can do than others because sometimes the
risk is just
a um a risk that's outside of our
control so if i give you the one around
financial sustainability there's not too
much we can do apart from lobbying
central government around the amount of
resources that we get
where others obviously there are things
that we can do
more proactively around project plan say
for example for birth 45 and you've
mentioned the actions that have been
taken by the council in relation to
governance so
my response to that unless the the chief
exec free chair is anything else to add
would be that we've got um action plans
in place to address some of these key
risks and they are trying to mitigate
those scores down as much as we can but
at the moment even with those actions in
place it wouldn't i feel it's the
scoring is still appropriate i'm hopeful
that as we progress those scores will
come down to reflect the progress that
we're making but at the comment moment
time i feel the scoring is fair and
accurate for the rest of the
organization's face
thank you chair um uh i've nothing
further to add to that
excellent explanation of risk scoring
chris i think just to provide some
accuracy around the or clarity around
burst four or five position
uh absolutely uh the uh submission was
withdrawn a few weeks back as a result
the requirement to accommodate the
eia the environmental impact assessment
that hasn't actually at this moment
changed the
risk in relation to the time scale for
the delivery of that project i think as
chris very rightly pointed out the
reason that it is significant for us uh
absolutely is that that if there is any
further delay as a result of some of
those
processes that we're following through
the local planning process and with the
marine management organization if they
if they are delayed then obviously that
may have consequences in relation to the
time scale and then obviously in
relation to potentially the risks
associated with additional costs but
just to reassure you we are working very
hard with all of the relevant
stakeholders including the mmo
who are also liaising with our local
planning authority to try and make sure
we align as efficiently as possible all
the appropriate processes that are
involved in actually achieving uh the
outcome that we need to achieve and and
that's part of the mitigation activity
that chris is referring to but just to
reassure it is totally on our agenda and
we are trying to manage it within our
ability and bring all of those things
together thank you thank you
thank you um any other questions or
comments
no okay um one from me chris um just on
page
there's two from me actually i lied
sorry um
obviously it's gonna be um on page 110
um where it talks about the homelessness
risk at the bottom the bottom paragraph
says the service has also seen a number
of members of staff leave the authority
recently and so resources within the
section are also stretched at the moment
although interim resourcing is being put
into place to ensure continuation of
service
and i just wondered um
where it says that there's been a number
of staff leave the authority
is there any work around sort of finding
the reasons as to why
they are leaving the authority you know
ex interviews what's the data behind is
there a common trend as to why they are
leaving and is it just have we only just
picked it up on the homelessness
department as well because that's that's
within that risk so i just wondered
whether there was any sort of
data or reasoning common trends that you
could pick out on
thank you chair yes um
uh
through you chair style may would still
um contribute to this as well because
with their nervous responsibilities hr
uh for has been an arena but we are
aware there are recruitment retention
areas um issues in some areas of the
organization we monitor those carefully
and look to um
establish how we can address those in
terms of this service in particular i
think there were um three officers in
particular i think they all have varying
personal reasons for their reasons for
departure i don't think there was any
particular trends um that
could pin it down and obviously there
were personal reasons of nature i didn't
really want to expand on them um in the
committee
um so
i don't think that there's something
inherently um
[Music]
at fault within the housing service
that's left led to those and so we need
to be concerned about but obviously
the fact that there are vacancies puts
service continuity at risk and that's
why the interims have been put in place
to ensure
there is that continuity available and i
know recruitment is um
sort of in train to recruit permanent
posts
thank you chris and the second one was
more around the other side
uh which is on page where it was 109 um
and this could just be a publishing
error i'm not sure but it talks about
obviously the extraordinary council
meeting being scheduled for the 2nd of
november
um is it just saying that because this
report was written away before or should
it be updated to reflect that it's
actually happened
yes i think that's a fair comment i'll
need to look into the timeline um in
terms of i think it was pro that
narrative was probably uh written a
while back again and wasn't picked up as
part of the review process um but
ultimately yes it should reflect that
that's a past event and not something
that's scheduled to happen still
thank you chris um
so the recommendation is uh for approval
please can i have a proposer and a
seconder to approve the review
uh a proposer of council blue at pew and
say second
you can't release it um and a second of
councillor
whitehead sorry i'm just completely out
of mind blank then uh secondary of
council whitehead uh unless i hear any
objection um i will take this as
approved
perfect
and we're now gonna move on to a gender
item eight i'd like to introduce estelle
culligan director of law and democracy
who will introduce this report
thanks very much chair let's put my
glasses on just bear with me a minute
can't see
so um if i'd invite you just to open the
document itself the annual governance
statement and just to say that um
i'm looking at it on the
web so unfortunately i don't have the
same numbering as you have so i'll just
refer to page numbers in the document
itself so one two three four five etc
um so i brought this before you because
uh it's an update of the annual
governance statement
which you considered at your meeting on
the 28th of july and at the time we
thought that last year's annual accounts
would be published in september
and so
what happens with the annual governance
statement is it's published annually at
or before the publication of the audited
accounts
so i brought it before you in july
because obviously it was important to
approve it before the anticipated
approval of the accounts and publication
in september
however there have been various delays
with the
with that audit and so they're not yet
published but i believe they will be
probably shortly hopefully
that's an optimistic statement um
hopefully there will be um we last
published we published last year's
annual government statement in december
so really it's important to get this
published and get this out there and
also since july we've had
we've had lots happening we've had the
statutory recommendations on the 12th of
october which we accepted on the 2nd of
november so i thought it was important
to bring you an updated document that
was as up-to-date as possible that
hopefully if you will approve then
i can ask the leader and the chief
executive to sign it off and we can get
it published on the website so just to
take you through it very quickly just to
let you know what changes i have made
so there's a section on external audit
on page six and that's just page six on
the pages not in the agenda
and i've updated that to refer to the
fact that they've made statutory
recommendations which we've accepted
and then on pages seven and eight it's a
section on general purposes committee
and i've referred to the fact that that
committee has adopted the grievance
procedure for statutory officers we've
got that process all set up
um then there's an item on disbanding of
east kent hr on page 10 and i've just
updated that to refer to the fact that
the in-house hr service started on the
first of september and jolly well it's
doing two so um that's a real
positive and then
let me have a look uh the item i think
which follows on from the item one
eastern hr is the item on issues raised
by this committee at the march meeting
in respects in respect of governance and
culture and again i've just referred to
the issuing of the stat rex on the 12th
of october
the action plan for 2021 22 at pages 12
and 13. i've updated that to include a
reference to
the statutory recommendations again and
also to update the amendments to the
constitution uh which have taken place
because there's a few more that we've
done recently
um
other than the other other than those
amendments the um annual government
statement is as previously approved on
the 28th of july
and
that's it basically fairly
straightforward
so if you have any questions i'm very
happy to answer them thanks very much
members any comments or questions
okay and i've got one comment um just
for a little bit of clarity so that it's
clear and i got a bit confused with it
but there's a sentence that says on page
five on your one i believe
um
the lack of an external quality
assessment eqa against the
psias is hereby disclosed as
non-conformance in this annual
governance statement what does that mean
and is there a particular reason why
that decision
has been made
thanks very much
i'd like to hand over to um
christine parker who's here from our uh
internal audit team who'll be able to
explain because that is her report in
the in the document thank you
thank you chair um
apologies this would have originated
from our annual report where psias would
have been explained in full it needs to
be um copied through so i'll make sure
that happens in future um
wording for the document so it is the
public sector internal audit standards
um and the comment is um
is made so one of the standards is that
every five years internal audit has an
external quality assessment carried out
and this has
been regularly
appears on the agenda with the
client officer group which is the four
section 151 officers from each of the
four councils making up our internal
audit partnership
the conclusion to date has been rather
than spend the money on having an
external quality assessment
they are content to rely on our own
self-assessment which one of the section
151 officers ordinarily from the dover
as we have that sort of direct reporting
line to him
reviews that
is something that we are about to meet
again in january and consider again we
have in the past
obtained uh quotations
from zipfer and the institute of
internal auditors and others
and and it is an expense that we've
considered um and so far haven't
actually taken undertaken in the past uh
before this requirement came in it was
something that external audit did under
the guise of the audit commission and
they probably did it every other year
and we had in in my experience only one
detailed
assessment
so yeah we do
report on this of course to the audit
and governments committee and the last
time we brought the results of our
self-assessment to committee was march
20
so we will be doing that again and bring
in the annual report we also report on
our
progress against any actions that we've
identified um so i hope that explains it
and apologies that is probably um a
little bit cryptic in it where it's
lifted out of our report but yes that so
it will be reconsidered again in january
by the the collective section 151
officers thank you
thank you
um
the recommendation is that a committee
agrees the annual governance statement
2020-21
and authorizes the leader and chief
executive to sign up sign it off for
2020 21 and for it to be published uh
please can have a proposal and a second
to agree the annual government statement
2020-21
proposed by council of pew
and seconded by councillor shrub thank
you unless i hear any objection i will
take this as approved
thank you
we'll now move on to item nine uh which
is the 2020 to 21 external audit
progress report and i'm going to hand
you back over to chris blundell who will
introduce introduce this on behalf of
grant thornton
thank you chad yes i'm afraid you'll
have to um do with me tonight instead of
the external auditors for their update
um there's not a huge amount to report
in terms of the update on the progress
of the order of the accounts as still
referred to in her presentation the
audit is still not completed i can't say
without any certainty when it will be
but we're not alone only nine percent of
local authority audits were completed by
the september deadline this year um
there is a resourcing and capacity issue
in the local authority audit mark market
at the moment um not only are there less
auditors available remote auditing is
harder to undertake than on-site
and they've got more complex audits to
undertake because of their regulator the
financial reporting council has
put more
requirements in place in terms of their
audit evidence and assessments they need
to undertake but the work they've done
so far is progressing reasonably well so
they've not found any mistakes on our
account so far so that's a win
but
touchwood that carries on in that vein
um
in terms of
the valley for money assessments on page
137
they're given an update on where they
are with with uh with a number of years
value for money opinions they're still
looking at all the way back to 1819
uh 1819 i'm expecting um that we will
get sort of an anniversary
qualified opinion in terms of our
contract arrangements that we had in
place for monitoring the contracts at
east kent housing but obviously the
council has already taken steps to
address those and then the other audits
that are ongoing
valley for money opinions
they largely again relate to
similar issues across those two years
our financial sustainability and some of
the matters in relation to governance
that have already been raised by the
auditors and their recommendations that
the council has
raised
so that really is a uh summary of where
we are with the audit at the moment
happy to take any questions
counselor ghana
thank you yeah thank you
my question does relate to the
last point you were making about the
value for money
um
reports
it's just for my clap for our clarity is
it fair to say that all of the
objections that were raised in each of
those value for money against each of
those value for money reports are
covered and dealt with
within the
section 24 report
um or are there other
objections
um that are separate to the section 24
report so in other words
once we
deal with the recommendations of the
section 24 report satisfactorily and we
move on
um that
i'm sure we can all see that in the
distance getting nearer but
that will happen one day once that's
done
will those be able to be signed off
those value for money reports
good question uh simple terms no there's
there's more to it so some of the
objections one relates to birth uh four
five in terms of arrangements there i'm
not aware of the details of it
at this moment in time i know the
auditor is considering it and will be
be progressing with that
and then some of the 1819 audits
they really should have been
concluded by now we will get them and as
part of the 2021 audits finding report
when they conclude it
there are issues there in relation to
contracts um so i mentioned east kent
housing there's one contract in relation
to parking that they investigated but um
didn't consider um and then uh another
issue in relation to parking fees as
well that we had a report from them so
it in summary there are more um matters
outside of the section 20 report but the
outcome of those would simply be that
they will provide an unqualified opinion
in terms of arrangements um
qualified opinion to provide value for
money which is an adverse opinion so
effectively this they're not happy with
our arrangements if that's the
conclusion they come to there's nothing
outside the section 24 matters that
they've already
reported that are of significant
substance to my knowledge that will
result in similar
stature recommendations being presented
because they are fairly rare and the
other things are i would say a more
regular
nature
ask one
related to the statutory recommendations
so
we obviously all attended the
extraordinary meeting and we received
the quite stark warning from the
external auditor about the urgency of
resolving these these matters
um is it would it be fair
for us on this committee
which isn't going to meet for another
three months i don't believe because we
meet quarterly to say that by the next
time we meet in a quarter in three
months
all of the
these four recommendations
should have been dealt with
and
um completed so as we've moved on
and that if anything any of these are
still outstanding by the next time we
meet
uh in three months then we're
we're we're in a bit of trouble
if if initially i could add but i will
then hand over um just the paul dosset i
think he he mentioned that six months
was sort of the time frame that he
specified but um given us of a
governance nature i think it'd be more
appropriate for
the chief exec or for
the acting monitoring officer to address
that
thank you chair um yes just to to
clarify the uh request or was by the
external launchers at council meeting
for
significant progress to have been made
within six months i think we would all
agree we certainly want to progress this
as quickly as possible
and ultimately there are four
recommendations some of those are much
more within our control but obviously
the ones regarding the independent
monitoring officer will require their
view
around actually how much time it's going
to take them to conclude matters and and
that's something that's still
being is still under discussion
okay
i mean i think ultimately sorry chair
just to say that i think actually we've
expressed our desire to have this done
as efficiently as possible but i think
we just need to be mindful that we want
it to be done properly so not to put
unnecessary pressure but obviously
recognizing the six-month time scale
any other questions or comments
brilliant um would members like to note
the report
perfect thank you uh moving on to agenda
item 10 appointment of external auditors
and it's chris blondell again
thank you uh this one i thank you josh
so this one hopefully is a bit more of a
straightforward paper pretty much a slam
dunk for decision um unless i present
this horribly um and
we come to some bizarre conclusion um
but ultimately we've got to procure
our new audit contract that has been
placed by the beginning of 2023-24
the current arrangements we have in
place have we procured for a national
framework and that is the recommended
approach to go forward again there's no
interest from other kent authorities to
have a joint procurement to this and if
we were to do it ourselves it's much
more likely that it would cost more and
there's a risk we might not even be
successful in pointing an order to so
going forward with a
the national framework scheme is is by
far the most advantageous scheme but it
does require full council decision um
and which needs to be given by the 11th
of march so the recommendation for the
committee is to recommend that action on
to council happy to take any questions
but i think this hopefully is a
relatively straightforward one unless
i've misinterpreted it
um are there any comments or questions
members would like to make
counselor pugh
sorry chris thank you thank you chair
and thank you chris i wasn't going to
ask any questions but soon as you said
it was really straightforward i thought
i might as well um no just just a couple
and i'm sure you can clarify them for me
um the first one is it says i think it's
.43
says auditors have been have also been
asking for additional fees to pay for
extra work so my first question is have
grant thornton asked us over the last
four or five year period
for extra fees to cover extra work
and also as well um it mentions in
i think it's in the current arrangements
and it says about the psaa
appoints somebody for us
um as our external auditor do we have a
say in who that is of the nine that are
listed in 4.2 or is it completely out of
our control
who we end up getting and
leading on from that if issues arise uh
with
that external auditor as you say in 4.1
um
some of them have been operating the
last couple of years uh it's been
extremely disappointing is there an
opportunity for us to change
if something does go wrong or is it that
we're completely locked in for those
three or four years
excellent questions thank you councillor
um
uh 4.3 um
yes that they have asked for additional
fees so there were a couple um last year
they asked for additional fees for the
work they did in relation to dreamlands
because obviously we had a disagreement
around the accounting issues and then
there were um some additional
requirements that have been put on them
by the financial reporting council to
look into the way
we account for our pensions that haven't
changed but the their auditing
requirements have changed so their fees
have gone up uh so for context um our
fees are currently around about eighty
thousand um but when the contract
started they were closer to fifty five
sixty so we have seen an increase in
fees over the period and the pssa have
to agree to those changes and fees
in terms of the next question
no we don't really have a choice the
pssa will appoint them they look to try
and have some commonality of appointment
across
a similar geography so gt
uh grant thornton have the largest uh
market share at the moment they've got
40 of the market and they ordered the
majority of um authorities in kent i
think all by a couple they've got um e y
ants and young
um in terms of issues yeah p s s p s
double a they effectively are they uh
the contract uh manager for us so we
have a mechanism to feed back but i
think it's
fair to say that's not been satisfactory
but i think the conclusion we've come to
is um a sector is it's kind of the
better the devil you know at the moment
and pssa have have promised improvements
going forward um we're hopeful that that
will translate into better auditor
performance but fundamentally the audit
market's not in a good shape at the
moment um and for us to take alternative
action i think would leave us in a
probably a much worse situation
any other questions or comments
perfect the recommendation is that the
governance and audit committee
recommends council that the invitation
to opt in to the national scheme for
auditor appointment is accepted police
can have a proposer and a seconder for
the recommendation
proposed by councillor cup and seconded
by councillor whitehead
unless i hear any objection i will take
this approved
thank you and that concludes the
business for tonight's meeting i declare
this meeting closed at 20 14 100 hours
uh thanks to everyone who participated
in those watching from home
the live stream of this meeting will now
end good night